[Musique]
en cette journée ensoleillée cinq
footballeurs américains des templiers
d'elancourt ont ressorti leurs ballons
depuis le déconfinement privé de séance
d'entraînement en club à cause du coc
u19 ces sportifs viennent volontairement
chaque semaine cinq matinées sur sept
dans ce parc de guyancourt objectif
s'entretenir physiquement et surtout
pouvoir regoûter à leur sport bien sûr
c'est important ça nous a manqué pendant
trois mois on et focus avec nos
objectifs et on revient toujours
s'entraîner avec lydie dans la tête de
jeu l'année prochaine on va vers le
futur est d avis que j'ai recueillis
autour de moi c'est comme une drogue
pour tout le monde franchement
et même si on aime tous les sports à peu
près le foot le basket le foot us on en
a besoin
les joueurs de football américain ne
sont pas les seuls à être en manque de
sport en ce moment les basketteurs
trappistes bamba cei s'entraîne seul sur
le terrain de sa ville en extérieur le
joueur l'essentiel l'entente le chesnay
versailles n'a plus joué depuis le mois
de mars
mais il veut garder la forme à 40 1 en
vue de la saison prochaine en nationale
3 ça va être technique à une vie des
halles dont on tire des posteurs et tout
ça donc on aura faire tout doucement
s'il ya du mont noir ont peu fait je
peux faire d un contrat de groupe 2 est
aussi plus chouchouté chute est beaucoup
plus contraignant les entraînements de
boxe se passe actuellement en extérieur
la dizaine de boxeurs de la team
farrugia il encourt se réunissent
régulièrement pour pratiquer leur
passion respectant les gestes barrières
et combats sont notamment interdits les
sportifs amateurs et professionnels du
club sont ce jour là sur une piste
d'athlétisme à trappes
chacun doit être presque à l'autre côté
du stade pour s'entraîner bon j'exagère
un peu mais c'est à peu près ça coince
abdos pompes
la musculation spécifique voilà ça reste
soft princesse ça fait plus aux
entraînements de vacances qu'autre chose
moi tous ces athlètes espère désormais
un retour à la normale rapide le
gouvernement a annoncé la réouverture
des salles de sport gymnase et piscine
pour le 22 juin prochain dans les
yvelines
il faudra sûrement patienter tout l'été
pour la reprise dans les clubs locaux